[Musique]
on passe maintenant à notre panel
politique avec ce soir j'osais Legault
Émilie Nicolas et Christian Dufour
bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir bonsoir on
commence avec vraiment la nouvelle qui a
fait la journée d'émission en bloc de ce
qui restait de la haute direction de
Hockey Canada donc tous les membres du
conseil d'administration parce que
n'oublions pas que la présidente par
intérim avait déjà démissionné le samedi
dernier et puis le Grand PDG Scott meet
ils sont tous partis s'est rendu
inévitable José c'est vraiment une
question jour ou deux même
oui mais c'est quand même trop peu trop
tard là cette c'est la torture de la
goutte là depuis quand même beaucoup
trop longtemps et évidemment c'est
nécessaire c'était essentiel
c'est pas c'est pas un changement de
culture là qui est nécessaire ok Canada
c'est carrément une révolution donc il
faut absolument que ces gens-là ça fait
des semaines qu'on le dit mais le plus
gros du travail reste à faire c'est à
dire comment rétablir la crédibilité de
Hockey Canada et comment rétablir la
confiance souci des joueurs et des
familles de jeunes joueurs et puis ça
parle aussi de ça sert à quoi un conseil
d'administration la ministre s'interroge
a réagi aujourd'hui la ministre fédérale
du sport et elle a dit ceci on va
l'écouter ensemble
finalement Emilie elle est en train de
dire là un conseil d'administration qui
ne fait pas son travail qui n'exécute
pas son devoir mais ça donne ce qu'on
vient de voir elle veut maintenant qu'on
repense même la formation de ce conseil
d'administration elle a pas le droit
elle de décider elle fait quand même des
suggestions en disant ça prend plus de
diversité ça prend des gens qui ont des
compétences qui ont des compétences
aussi dans les enjeux criant
actuellement comme tous ces cas
d'agressions sexuels débutent pouvoir
etc et qui ont fait les manchettes
oui mais effectivement le pas c'est ce
qui est un peu compliqué dans ce dossier
là c'est que la ministre Paul pouvoir
décisionnelle sur la composition du
conseil d'administration de Hockey
Canada c'est pas une société d'État ceci
dit le gouvernement aussi avait aussi
des leviers depuis plusieurs semaines au
niveau du financement mais c'est vrai
que la vaste majorité du financement de
Hockey Canada vient des commanditaires
et ensuite la base organisationnelle
donc je pense que la une des raisons
pour lesquelles ça a pris autant de
temps ce que ça bouge c'est que ça a
pris beaucoup de temps avant que
plusieurs commentaires commencent à
lever le temps ça peut aussi beaucoup de
temps avant que les sections
provinciales commencent à enlever le ton
aussi et là je pense que maintenant
lorsque la municipale et qu'elle veut un
changement culture maintenant je pense
que ça risque de fonctionner justement
parce que les commentaires ont fini par
se lever parce que les associations de
hockey provinciales ont fini par se
lever mais ça a pris en essentiellement
briser il a fallu briser le mur du
silence et la solidarité dans le milieu
du hockey avant arriver à ce que la
ministre fasse écouter là je pense que
ça risque entre j'ai espoir que ça
risque de débloquer à partir de là
Christian le ministre dit c'est pas pour
demain là qu'on recommence le
financement fédéral de cette organisme
là je veux devoir voir des preuves que
du changement mais elle est pas la seule
à le dire Émilie parlait du pouvoir des
commanditaires il y a des commanditaires
aussi qui disent on attend de voir des
changements nous aussi avant d'investir
à nouveau c'est bien moi et parce que
bon c'est très spectaculaire ce qui est
arrivé aujourd'hui mais c'est ce que
parler en fait c'est pas l'esprit de Me
Too c'est pas le respect des femmes
c'est pas le refus des agressions
sexuelles c'est le cash l'argent donc on
voit qu'il y a une résistance très
grande ça a pris beaucoup de temps avant
que cette réaction là bon massive quand
même je pense que c'est pas rien le
symbole est là mais on voit que c'est
une culture en fait qui est très
réticente c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
à des changements donc ça se fera pas
magiquement comme tel mais c'est
l'argent il veut parler on peut même
boire un bon côté bah au départ non le
but de dire en tout cas ces questions là
il y a aussi des impacts financiers qui
oblige les organismes à bouger mais
c'est ça que je retiens en fait c'est
l'argent qui a parlé c'est pas vrai
quand vous parlez d'argent est-ce que
vous vous faites partie de ceux qui
disent j'aimerais savoir dans quelles
conditions le PDG accepter de partir
est-ce qu'il a reçu une prime cet
homme-là une prime de départ je pense
pas ça pour terminer même plus que
faisant parler ça pourrait être
intéressant de le savoir non mais
spontanément je pense pas ça moi
aujourd'hui j'ai surtout noté le côté
spectaculaire ils sont tous partis donc
ça fait la nouvelle on en parle ce soir
donc tout ça est très très positif
peut-être que dans deux trois jours on
va apprendre que on les a acheté pour
qu'il partent je sais pas là moi je peux
être un peu naïf mais je pense pas
spontanément à ces choses là et parlons
José là-dedans même si on n'est pas des
experts de hockey leadership qui a
exercé ok Québec en étant quand même la
première organisation provinciale à dire
moi là je vais cesser de verser mes
cotisations qu'on prélève des jeunes
joueurs à cette organisme là qui ne fait
pas son travail
c'est là qu'on voit que peut-être dans
certains cas et c'est ça qui est
vraiment élabgie d'allumage
que c'est d'accord avec ce que Christian
vient dire mais que c'est peut-être pas
que l'argent aussi c'est que là il y
avait vraiment le vase débordé
littéralement de partout écoutez c'était
extrêmement grave ce dont on parle et si
on peut revenir à la question de
l'argent il y a aussi tous ces montants
là que ok Canada a utilisé pour
camoufler des cas d'abus sexuels ou pour
empêcher des poursuites etc donc ça le
scandale il est vraiment là et
chapeau au Québec mais encore une fois
tout ça a pris beaucoup de temps quand
même le chapeau ok Québec mais là Émilie
jour lance la question ici il y a quand
même des associations provinciales qui
elles ne voulait pas blâmer ok Canada
celle de l'Ouest en particulier était
encore ok alors ça aussi ça parle de la
culture c'est pas juste ça ok Canada qui
est cette culture là
non absolument c'est partout c'est un
milieu qui semble extrêmement
conservateur puis bon vous donner des
stations de l'Ouest et aussi des
associations je pense à Internet qui
disaient ça on va attendre un rapport de
pour essayer de voir c'est la culture à
l'intérieur ici pire que ça avant de
finalement se
prononcer puis je pense que aussi je
veux dire toutes les fonds qui ont été
créés etc on parle de quelque chose qui
date de plusieurs années les coques sont
ressortis date aussi de plusieurs années
donc faut comprendre que c'est des
pratiques qui ont été mises en place pas
nécessairement par l'océan actuel mais
par des gens bien avant aussi que le
siècle perpétré aussi ces gens-là sont
employeurs le milieu du hockey est petit
il y a des gens qui ont fait partie de
de ces prises de décisions là qui sont
peut-être dans d'autres niveaux
d'influence très important aussi pour
pour le hockey Canadiens donc c'est ça
qui est difficile je pense dans un
dossier comme ça c'est de réaliser qui
est essentiellement lorsqu'on tire sur
ce genre de culture là c'est très
difficile de ne pas éc pousser à peu
près plusieurs têtes décisionnels
conjoint et je pense que c'est ce qui
fait que le milieu prend du temps à
réagir et que le milieu se protège mais
je pense aussi que ça ça contribue
peut-être au niveau de je veux dire
colère et peut-être des goûts publics
par rapport à ce qui se passe en ce
moment mais là l'État sont tombées alors
il y aura ce comité de transition qui va
être formé et puis on verra par la suite
en qui on va choisir pour être à nouveau
sur ce conseil d'administration qui va
devenir le nouveau grand patron ou la
nouvelle grand patronne ça pourrait être
une femme aussi le PDG Christian c'est
une bonne nouvelle quand même faut pas
toujours être négatif c'est une très
bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui il y a une
sanction qui est arrivé puis en même
temps moi je suis pas si étonné que ça
veut dire Émilie parler du fait que
c'est un milieu conservateur mais c'est
un milieu de gars c'est là ok il en
trouve quand même à une culture
traditionnelle de gars très très
compétitive qui résiste en fait à ces
choses-là évidemment dans la mesure où
il y a des agressions puis sexuelles
c'est totalement inacceptable mais moi
ça m'étonne pas à ce point-là
qui fait la même culturel ancien mais il
y a comme un bastion qui vient de tomber
et il faut s'en réjouir il faut être
optimiste pour l'avenir faut pas juste
être négatif
[Rires]
de ce que dit aujourd'hui le chef du
Parti québécois Paul Saint-Pierre de La
Mondon il a convaincu un point de presse
pour annoncer qu'il refusait de prêter
serment parce que c'est obligatoire il
doit prêter serment pour devenir député
c'est une tradition qu'on a ici qu'on a
dans toutes les provinces canadiennes
alors c'est plus prêté serment à l'arrêt
maintenant c'est au roi Charles bien
entendu c'est le 21 octobre son
assermentation il dit je vous avais
prévenu je vous l'avais dit lors du
débat des chefs que je ferais ça voici
un extrait de ce qu'il a dit ce matin
comment la pratique a évolué c'est qu'on
demande aux députés de faire les deux
serments l'un après l'autre faire un
serment en de loyauté envers le peuple
québécois qu'ensuite un serment de
loyauté envers le roi d'Angleterre
moi ce que je vous dis ce matin c'est à
sa face même c'est un conflit d'intérêt
on ne peut pas servir deux mètres
lorsqu'on sait que ces intérêts là sont
contradictoires
est-ce que vous pensez de ça Christian
vous waouh ma première réaction j'ai
trouvé que c'était un coup des clubs
avec ce dont il est porteurs jusqu'à
présent on sait que la monarchie est un
anacronisme au Canada puis au Québec en
plus c'est un symbole colonial ça va
être d'autres députés des autres partis
qui se joignaient à lui dans son
opération en fait qui est de rompre avec
l'ordre conceptionnel canadien au fond
peut-être ça peut être intéressant mais
moi je dis essayer par le passé Québec
solidaire avait essayé exactement et ça
a toujours fini au fond qui ont cédé et
puis qui l'ont prêté le fameux serment à
la reine à l'époque en privé donc c'est
quand même faut aussi autant c'est un
symbole colonial autant il y a des
choses beaucoup plus graves qui menacent
au Québec que la monarchie britannique
là je peux pas dire que ça dérange à ce
point-là les gens donc au fil d'arriver
s'il reste seul avec ces deux autres
députés pékistes ça peut être humiliant
aussi c'est un des réduit à le prêter le
serment mais si d'autres parties se
joignent à lui députés pardon se
joignaient à lui qui dans le contexte
actuel me semble ça prête comme une
espèce de rébelliance symbolique par
rapport à un autre colonial qu'on admet
au Québec et là ça pourrait me dire
quelque part mais ma première réaction
j'ai trouvé ça quand même audacieux mais
dangereux voyez-vous une rébellion
Venise vous José
non mais non écoutez moi ce que je l'ai
vu ce matin je me suis dit deux choses
la première c'est que bon pas
saint-pierre-flammond donc continue à
faire de la politique autrement ça c'est
pour ça que les gens l'apprécient qu'ils
aient voté ou non pour son parti la
deuxième chose c'est que oui c'est un
geste d'acieux mais qui à mon humble
avis ne comporte aucun risque politique
pour le chef du Parti québécois parce
que s'il remporte la mise parce que là
on c'est possible que ce soit que ça va
créer un précédent c'est possible que le
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale permet
aussi ou pour exclure cette possibilité
là donc un précédent important se récré
et si jamais il ne réussit pas et bien
tout d'abord ces troupes mais aussi les
Québécois vont pouvoir dire ben au moins
lui il s'est essayé et au moins il s'est
tenu debout et pour une question quand
même c'est une question de principe mais
si réussie
ah non mais non ils vont être non je
pense que on lui a posé la question en
point de presse aujourd'hui et il a dit
bon il répondait un peu similaire là bon
moi je ne crois pas que on m'empêchait
de sier ce qui voulait dire on trouvera
une manière de siéger et bien entendu
écouter cet homme-là c'est battu bête et
ongles pour être sûr
pas à l'Assemblée nationale avec ce qui
arrive au Parti québécois donc non c'est
vraiment moi j'ai vu ça vraiment comme
une situation sur le plan politique qui
est gagnant-gagnante pour pour Monsieur
pspp mais aussi en même temps parce que
la politique c'est ce n'est pas fait que
de politique publique c'est fait aussi
de symbole et sur le plan des symboles
et bien il a des chances de créer un
précédent important Émilie là-dessus
je trouve que c'est pas quelque chose
qui m'en a pas les ressources publiques
souvent on dit les Québécois d'autres
priorité
de l'Assemblée nationale pour garder
c'est pour pas faire son serment
autrement ça empêche pas l'état de
fonctionner ça empêche pas les autres
priorités des Québécois d'être
adressé donc c'est pas là le débat je
pense aussi que c'est vrai que plusieurs
autres députés qui se sont essayés avant
ceci dit à reine Élisabeth et le roi
Charles III c'est pas la même chose et
je pense qu'il y a un contexte qui qui
fait en sorte que il y a peut-être la
fenêtre est peut-être un peu plus
ouverte pour maintenant pour passer à
autre chose parce que la reine Elizabeth
II était un
symbole plus grand je pense peut-être
même que que la monarchie au sens où
c'est une figure politique est traversée
tout le 20e siècle il est déjà dans moi
donc je pense à peu près tout le monde
ici je veux dire les gens les gens sont
nés il était déjà souveraine donc c'est
tandis que le roi Charles III je pense
que d'un point de vue ça colle de
popularité personnelle c'est c'est autre
chose et il y a un mouvement de
réflexion sur la monarchie qui qui
s'amorce ailleurs dans le commonwear
donc dans ce sens-là je pense que poser
la question de maintenant et je pense
que c'est pertinent la question c'est
pas de savoir si le Canada sort de la
monarchie aujourd'hui c'est savoir si
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on fait respecter
en fait les règlements qui demandent de
prêter serment au à Charleroi je pense
que ce que Paul Saint-Pierre va tester
c'est si oui ou non en fait si on
désobéissent so what qu'est-ce qui se
passe est-ce que des conséquences en
réalité c'est ce que disait Patrick
Taillon constitutionnaliste aussi
là-dessus Christian dernier mot
là-dessus parce que pour Monsieur
Taillon on peut pas lui donner cette
autorisation là mais il disait la
question en fait c'est qu'elles sont les
conséquences de ça ce qu'on va fermer
les yeux puis on laisse passer pareil
c'est ça mais je pense pas qu'on va
former les jupes on va laisser passer
pareil parce qu'on des normes
constitutionnels et moi ce que je trouve
le paradoxe c'est que c'est clair que la
monarchie au Canada c'est un
anachronisme au Québec c'est du
colonialiste mais c'est tellement
compliqué à changer que moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on va abolir la
monarchie au Royaume-Uni avant d'abolir
au Canada ah oui
vraiment même si c'est un acronix c'est
colonial on est vraiment pas avec ça bon
ben ça sera notre mot de la fête ce soir
merci
merci bonsoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI